a playoffs well they're back on but the
games are not going to start tonight
last night the milwaukee bucks started a
protest against the kenosha shooting
by holding a strike and refusing to play
soon major league baseball the wnba and
professional soccer also
postponed games in solidarity basketball
analyst chris webber applauded those who
took a stand on television
praising the young people leading the
way
we know nothing is going to change we
get it martin luther king got shot and
risked his life mega evers if we've seen
this and all of our heroes
constantly taken down we understand it's
not gonna end
but that does not mean young men that
you don't do anything
after speaking with elected officials in
wisconsin by phone last night
the bucks released a collective
statement calling for change
they want the police officers and
blake's shooting held accountable
players are also calling for the
wisconsin state legislature to address
police brutality and criminal justice
reform